new tropical system comes as puerto rico
tries to recover from the effects of
hurricane maria CBS News correspondent
David Wagner reported from the island
for more than two weeks he showed how
Puerto Rico struggled without easy
access to food water or power the winds
are ferocious right now gusting above
120 miles per hour the communication has
been cut power is out folks here aren't
even able to reach relatives I know that
leaders aren't supposed to cry and
especially not on TV but we are having a
humanitarian crisis even the hospitals
need help there's only one operating
room that's functioning right now these
are Americans sitting in line sleeping
in their car desperately trying to get
fuel the first person we saw when we got
here was the mayor and he said go
anywhere and you will find destruction
before I suffer people are trying more
than what Childers are trying but the
main things that we had to work to
we keep hopeful life David good morning
and welcome studio 57 first of all
congratulations on your reporting from
there help us understand where Puerto
Rico is today
Puerto Rico 90% of the island is without
power a majority of the hospitals don't
have their own power to operate and last
night a hospital in uma Cal had to be
evacuated when the power grid at the
hospital went down those patients had to
be moved on board the floating Hospital
the u.s. naval ship comfort charlie it
is an emergency on that island 14 days
after the storm made landfall I've never
covered a national disaster where the
emergency was endless and I thought like
you brought so much attention to that
not only in your reporting here on CBS
but the stuff you posted on social media
and then people were asking you to try
and find help there was a moment Nora
where nobody could find out about their
loved ones on the island and people on
the island couldn't let anybody know
they were okay so they started reaching
out to us can you tell me about the
mudslide that just happened here what
should I do and so instead of waiting
until the next morning or the next show
to report it
we started making calls when we went to
the airport there were thousands of
people sleeping on the floor and
children naked sweating being fanned by
their parents I went to the governor and
I said what can you do what can those
people he said well no we took care of
it and I said I showed him the video on
my phone and he said we're gonna send
aid we're not there to actually be a
first responder but if you can help get
action for the people who so desperately
need it I think that's journalism - do
you think the president was taken to the
right places because he seemed to
indicate at one point he said to
somebody there have a good time or you
all don't need flashlights he's being
criticized for the way that he threw the
roll of paper towels into the crowd did
you think he was really given a sense of
how bad it is there I'll answer that
question this way the president didn't
see the worst of it Gill the central
part of the island where people are
still bathing in stream water and
drinking from it mr. Trump was not able
to see I've talked to my doorman last
night I came in and he said just today
was I able to reach my mother just today
when I walked into the airport at JFK
last night there were people who came up
who were in tears because some of the
only ways that they've been able to find
out where their loved what's going on
with our loved ones live is through
television or social media the impact of
journalism on this story has been like
none
experienced before in terms of actually
being able to see questions making a
difference in getting action if you
could say one thing that they need most
what is it money they're in debt they're
in bankruptcy and the rebuilding will be
unbelievable
thanks to you've done incredible
reporting thank you so much